[Music]
combat toe
with the king
we back babies situations is getting
brighter
the fights are getting hyper
now i wanted to do this with earl spence
when he was gonna fight pacquiao right i
wanted to to
to to come back
to the youtube scene
with that big fight
[Music]
and that would have set up something
else
but right now we have
something that we haven't seen in a long
time an undisputed champion the first
undisputed champion in a super
middleweight division
now if this could be done
by canelo
as the first
mexican
unified champion
a super middleweight ever
he
is going for julio cesar chavez
seniors
uh
title of probably one of the best
mexican fighters
to come out of mexico
okay so
when you hear canelo talking you're
hearing a lot about legacy
hearing a lot about his history a lot
about
what he wants uh the world to remember
him by
now we have caleb sweetheart plants
and caleb plant
he seems unassuming
you're looking at him he's the ibf
champion
he stands uh i think six foot one with a
74 reach inch reach he's an orthodox
fighter
um
zero losses
and he's a counter puncher
boxer
okay um
not too heavy on the power
but if you don't know caleb plan he only
only has 12 knockouts so that means that
you know you can see a majority of his
fights
if you look at i think he's like a 62
percent uh knockout artist
if that high probably 40
48
i probably got the ratios backwards um
that lets you know that he's there to
box
so kayla plant you may not know him and
you know we know canelo for his uh i
believe it's um
56
victories
with 38 knockouts um
with one loss
so
we understand exactly who canelo is uh
he's been a pay-per-view fighter for a
very long time i believe this is caleb
plant's first pay-per-view
so
let's get the elephant out the room
everybody assumes that this right now is
canelo's uh
crowning
day
why wouldn't you believe that he has
fought the likes of miguel colto
uh floyd mayweather sugar shane
he has four individuals
that make you say
he's an icon
he's a legend
he's the walking embodiment of
the mexican spirit
why wouldn't this night be any other
than the same thing that we always see
from him
but in the back of your mind you have
something itching in the back of your
mind
you remember that boy floyd
canelo's first title shot right
how hard is it to win your first title
shot i guess you have all these jitters
just the first big pay-per-view you're
going through this is this is some crazy
stuff here right
so he goes through and what does floyd
does
he beats him he beats the young boy
now it was a split decision i didn't see
it as a split decision i thought floyd
beat him straight out right but
understand
you know um when there's buying power
behind a
fighter
promoters he was uh being promoted by
golden boy at the time
and we will get into that uh
boxing is corrupt let's be real
so one of those is in pocket but the big
motor was behind floyd
shout out to al haymon
uh money team
floyd took him to school
caught the boy when he was green
danced on him
see foloid is a defensively sound
master
when it comes to defense
and when it comes to defense uh
foot placement arm placement body
position
means a lot it's just not how you keep
your hands up here
is what you do with your feet your hands
your body and everything at all times so
he's defensively sounding he's an
offensive genius
places punches
doesn't have to throw a lot
back to
the two combatants
canelo alvarez
is
defensively sound
offensively a masterpiece
and probably right now one of the
complete fighters that we have fighting
today
he avoids a certain type of fighter that
can give him
the level of difficulty that he does not
want
to face
and to caleb plant
caleb plant is like i told you a boxing
counter puncher with not too much power
but just enough to un let you know who
the hell he is at all times
he has an open hand style of combat
much like pinella whitaker
but pennell whitaker was more
defensively sound caleb plant is
just the same as pinella whitaker if you
watch it but not a southpaw but gabe
pinel whittaker
rest in peace sweepy
the edge was he was a southpaw
with this style
didn't clinch much kayla plant doesn't
clinch much
he uses foot placement hand speed and
timing to offset his opponents
perfectly placed shot here followed by a
perfectly placed shot here then you find
yourself on the canvas looking up like
how the hell did i get here and it
wasn't hard shots
and he narrowly
escapes defeat
his first title fight for the ibf
championship
it was kind of rough at certain points
but he controlled the fight
[Music]
at all times
so let's get to the prediction area
there's things in both fighters that we
like
so we're going to go for power we're
going to have to give canelo a 10. are
we going to go for speed we're gonna
have to give canelo a seven eight i give
him an eight a solid eight because he's
not the fastest but he
definitely counter punches
like one of the best
when we go to sharpness we're going to
give canelo a 10
because he's sharp
see
timing beats speed all the time
canelo has perfect timing
so when we go to timing can now we'll
get to 10.
when we go to foot movement canelo can
be flat-footed at times so we're going
to have to give him a six
durability we're going to have to give
canelo a 10.
we haven't seen canal cut up beat up
broken in any fight
so overall
this fighter is standing at a 9.5
right
going in we know exactly who he is
caleb plant going into this fight
we're going to say boxing ability a 10
defensive prowess we're going to give
him a seven
because he can be hit
and how he takes shots
is going to be the key asset in this
fight
footwork
makes him
outstanding when it comes to this
situation
because his foot placement hand
placement makes him a tactician
so we're going to go with sharpness he's
not as sharp as canelo
no
not at all
combination punches he does better
combinations than canelo
so the overall rating of this fighter
that you would give when you go to
durability you can't give him a great
durability rating because i will give
his durability a five
that will come into fact into this fight
so the rating that i would give this
fighter going into this fight during the
criteria that i'm looking at and i don't
judge the criteria is that the same i'm
just talking about the positives i'm
talking about a little bit of negatives
but when i group them the same when i
group them into position
i give kayla plant
a 8.4
as a fighter
now
we want to see
if the champ has lost a step
and we're talking about canelo
we also want to see
if caleb plant
[Music]
can ascend to the champs level
is this
his fight
to show the world
who he is
can he put it all together
one night
one fight
for all
the chips
all
the marbles
can
he
do it
this is the question that we ask
ourselves
now betting man will say this a betting
man will give canelo
the kale late
round corner stoppage
caleb clamp face can't hold up
canelo becomes the undisputed super
middleweight champion
canelo weighed in at 168 kayla plant
weighed in at 167
but there's something here
cable plant has a little bit of
something extra
he has that moxie that arrogance that
swagger that is needed
he has a rhythm
that we only see
in some of the great
african-american fighters
he has a swag
that is undeniable
he has a confidence
that is unshakable and it should be
because you know what he has that canelo
doesn't have
that oh
when it comes to losses
so when they're stating
56
and 46 knockouts when the one loss
by floyd money mayweather
there was one dude out there who beat
you
canelo has to eat that
when caleb plant steps up there and it
says 20
and oh with 12 knockouts there was
nobody
that figured out that puzzle
remember when i tell you
it's hard to teach a undefeated fighter
how to lose
they heart don't know it
canelo knows what defeat smells like
he's been there
there's probably a little bit removed
from his mind
but can caleb plant
make him remember
why he avoids fighters
of this nature
[Music]
i pick kayla plant
by 12 round split decision
if i'm a betting man and i'm betting
cash
i'm going to put my cash on canelo
and i'm going to say by late round
stoppage which would be probably the
ninth round or eighth round
[Music]
but i'm going with my heart here
and i think sometimes you get a little
bit of magic
in that little bit of magic might be
that thing
that keeps caleb plant
undefeated
at the end of the night
this is combat talk with the king
back to be back baby i love it nothing
like this
watch the fight talk to me tomorrow
night lord's podcast 11 a.m during
football season
tell me how wrong i was
or come bend the knee to the king
a lot of people do it
[Music]